this just broke just a little bit before
we started the show this is from the
citizens Free Press Jim Jordan is
running for speaker of the house and now
to bring this thing full freaking Circle
check this out tweet from Thomas Massey
who was on the McCarthy side of this
thing my first choice if he will run Jim
Jordan and then a tweet from Matt Gates
who is obviously on the Matt gates side
of this thing my mentor Jim Jordan would
be great all right so maybe just maybe
guys we will get a little Unity out of
the Republicans will it do all of the
things that Matt Gates wants I don't
know will it do all the things that
Thomas Massey wants I don't know but I
do know that I've interviewed Jim Jordan
a bunch of times I know that he gets the
issues I know that he's a deep defender
of free speech in the Constitution and
everything else we shall see what
happens
oh